wouldn't it be the most ridiculous story
ever told if the boy who couldn't read
and write 18 gets a PhD before he's
30 that's Cambridge Professor Jason AR
and his story is the most ridiculous
ever told but he didn't do it alone and
sometimes you don't need a thousand
people to want you to win you just need
one or
two Jason's Story got off to a tough
start he was diagnosed with autism and
Global development delay and was
non-verbal my processing is very very
slow so cognitively that has always been
a problem that's the reason why things
happen later for me then they should
have done four or five hours of speech
therapy a day from the age of three
there is nothing to suggest that any of
this is working at 11 go into this room
we go through the same kind of warmup
exercises as we normally did the speech
therapist and said to me hello Jason as
she always did and I just responded
hello it's quite a strange thing to hear
your own voice for the first time when
you're 11 I didn't expect my voice to
sound like this I think the first time I
saw I was like 15 that was like an
experience that was orgasmic oh these
SAR words this like am I using them in
the right
context Jason's mother was the first to
instill in him a valuable life
lesson so she had done a lot of research
herself she knew that an autistic trait
was repetition she normalized things a
lot in a sport like snooker repetitions
are quite an important thing you assess
a shot you cute a shot you feather it's
the same thing over and over and over
again and her whole thing was that he
might be able to apply it to other areas
of his life for example speaking and in
particular being a literate it's hard to
say if it worked or not it well in terms
of the snooker it did because I became a
really good snooker player but having a
strategy to succeed in life wasn't
enough Jason still needed something we
could all do with a good teacher I think
teachers who care are absolutely vital
the caring side of education is the most
important thing when I was with him in
his classes he just didn't make me feel
any different and he just took an
interest he took such an interest he
gave people the most important thing you
can give any human being he gave them
agency and a sense of importance and
just always felt like he wanted me to
win hearing that that Jason looked up to
me and valued me is actually really
humbling and it it just makes you very
aware that as a teacher that the impact
you can have is is huge if I hadn't met
Sandro I wouldn't be sat in front of you
now Jason has been a a special case I
think he might life I met him in 2003 he
didn't know how to write I felt
something on the day I must help this
guy there was something about Sandra's
approach that took Jason back to his
past and this time he was ready Sandra's
whole thing was repetition just doing
phonics doing literacy doing reading and
writing over and over again went over
and over and over with the same topics
until he's mastering it they tell me
every day you're great you're going to
do do something great every single day
but you have to be disciplined Jason it
need someone to say look you're capable
of doing things you're going to achieve
it you know let's do it together and one
of the things he said to me is like look
Jason you have this indominable will
that is going to be your thing then I
kind of thought right I'm just going to
try as hard as possible so when I got to
University that's the approach I took
now Jason being Jason he didn't just
stop at University in my second year of
uni I had a lecturer who just got their
PHD kind of went back and said to SRO
like what's a PhD I want to try and do
one and he said Jason we can do this and
once Jason started he couldn't stop he
made it all the way to becoming one of
the youngest professors ever at
Cambridge and it might not stop there
all of these lessons go back to being 14
15 16 being taught these things by Mr
trace and then it kind of being taken to
another level with Sandro and working on
the fact that my only two strengths are
that I've got a lot of Will on
determination I'm good with people and I
remember standing there thinking you
know you're in a situation where you're
on the cusp of doing something that
you've always wanted to do enjoy
it